so he does have all the tricks Troy was
right you do need all the tricks comes
naturally but it's still like you know
things that other people don't what kind
of things what kind of tricks yeah we
don't want mo kennyman running around so
you don't want to give away the see why
would you give my wailing into Nani they
don't let him get ya like you have to
now can say anything to anybody
although some of the women have said
they don't enjoy him at this point cuz
he's really you know against ninety but
he has the fifties you know what you
know what I don't I haven't done I don't
really do but actually the woman but but
Jim finds it like mind-boggling eat ass
you know that like Jim it's one of his
favorite hobbies I don't do it
and I got it something that the Candyman
does or is it something that you really
don't need in your repertoire that needs
to be added or no that's silly question
that's a secret it is I don't why is
that a secret because then guys my stop
doing will start doing it oh I see you
don't want to tell them you can't be
have this many women and not even do you
know I literally do that if someone
agrees to have lunch on a tinder date
it's the first thing I offering well
then let me ask you if he goes from one
girl to the next does the one girl be
like brush your teeth and four lipsticks
and drinks or anything it's an issue
different go yes the mouth is different
when it's somebody else's mouth you know
just him going one-on-one with the girls
like we all go yeah at each other as
well like a human centipede